hey everyone how's it going I hope you
are well so this is the second part of a
two-part video series where we talk
about internships with my friend Kelsey
Kelsey would you like to introduce
yourself sure hi I'm Kelsey I make a
channel called Kelsey makes things on
which I make things with code I make
videos about my life at college and new
grad life in the near future and yeah if
you're interested in check it out yeah
there will be a link to her channel in
the description marks down below so like
I said this is the second part of a
two-part series around internships the
first part was around why are
internships important what are some of
the things that you can get from an
internship so if you are asking those
questions right now they'll go click the
link in the card right there and there
will also be a link to the video in the
description box down below so this video
is going to talk more about the how to
actually get an internship Kelsey has a
lot of experience of this because she's
a college student had an internship in
Ohio and so it's great to have her here
to talk about her and experiences and
what she thinks is really important
right now in 2019 to get an internship a
slight disclaimer I feel like I'm not
like necessarily the best source on how
to get an internship I didn't have like
ten internships I didn't study
obsessively for the interviews for eight
hours straight every day I'm not like
that this video isn't going to be like
that we're gonna talk about some points
that may be obvious to people working in
tech now but may not be obvious to
people who are just getting into it yeah
because I think honestly 10 10
internships it's actually kind of
unrealistic and the reality of it is is
that there's so many different ways to
get into the industry and we have had
two very different ways of getting to
where we are and we just want to offer
that up we want everyone to know that
there are so many ways of getting into
the tech industry that you don't
necessarily have to even have had an
internship at one of the thing companies
I know I didn't sure the game is
different now and I think that some of
the tips that we're going to talk about
today will be really helpful but there
is a way to navigate this industry that
feels authentic to you that feels
reachable and doable and
want to talk about that more on my
channel so I'm super glad and excited to
be talking about this today so to set
the stage a little bit I want to talk a
little bit about the interviews for
internships and kind of just talk about
what it's like today what is the game
right now Kelsey what do you think yeah
when you said the game I was like I feel
that viscerally yeah for sure it is a
game and I think that people who don't
try to play this game people who might
not study for technical interviews maybe
you'll be super lucky and you'll just
happen to be really good at that but for
the great majority of people that is not
the case everyone plays this game to
some extent in fact there's an industry
made out of preparing for technical
interviews sometimes traditional
technical interviews or they ask you
with algorithms questions in a
time-limited setting sometimes these are
not great indicators of how good you are
as an engineer on the most basic level
these are supposed to be an indication
of your engineering ability and your
potential but sometimes this game will
be unfair to people who maybe just
didn't know that they had to practice as
much people learn I definitely learned I
remember my first technical interview
where it was on the phone I was sitting
on my bed I remember this so well
because it was so much Ematic yeah I was
asked to it like never reverse a stack
or something without using external data
structures and I had I kind of just
froze I started talking about FIFO LIFO
and what a stack was what a queue was I
was I was just kind of spewing
information because I just didn't know
how to approach this situation of course
I learned a little bit more throughout
the years but at that moment I felt like
a failure and I was like do I will I
ever get a job and that was just so
demoralizing but had I known that it is
such a game back then I don't think I
would have felt the same way and I think
I would have approached it a little bit
differently a lot of these internship
interviews like you
rythmic their traditional technical
interview questions but then when you
get to the internship they're like make
mistakes learn a lot of things like
you're gonna be great having been on the
industry side for a little while now I'm
noticing it's just like companies have a
really hard time assessing who's right
for a job and the technical interview is
really common it works sort of well it's
definitely broken but that's kind of the
best that they've got for now so it's
kind of this weird like this is the best
that we've got I'm sorry and want you
here yeah we love to have you it's
definitely not perfect and I think
that's maybe an important thing to know
when you are doing these interviews for
internships that the companies aren't
perfect the interviews aren't perfect
and also you're not perfect and we're
all just trying to get better and
improve ourselves and learn new skills
and figure out where do we fit in this
world that's a hard ask question to
answer but we're trying our best and I
think that if we can all just kind of
talk about it openly and help each other
move through this then it gets a little
bit easier so now we're going to get
into what are our tips for getting
internships for getting internships yeah
so the first thing before you get
interviewed is you have to get the
interview and it's so hard it's very
hard one of the first things that people
will talk about is make sure your resume
is up to date so I was always wondering
what does that mean how do I have enough
today and a good resume especially if I
have not much to put on it so I think on
your resume you want to focus on your
strengths if you've worked on some
personal projects that you think would
be cool to talk about but you don't have
much industry experience definitely
focus on your projects if you have a
good GPA put it on your resume one thing
that really helped me when I was in
college was getting friends to review my
resume because also at a certain point
you kind of lose yourself in the resume
and you're like I don't know if this
sounds good or not I mean getting
someone else's perspective especially a
friend especially if they've had
internships before and might know how to
cater that resume to a company or to a
specific person
if you can get like professors to look
at your resume the more eyes you can get
on your resume the more polished it can
be and that can be really helpful just
to get some more feedback there's so
many resources online around how to
build a good resume as well and we can't
cover that in this video here today but
we will leave some resources in the
description box down below so be sure to
check this out so now that you have your
resume how do you apply for jobs the
first thing that I would say is start
applying as early as you can starting to
apply in the fall before the summer of
the internship is when a lot of these
big employers are looking for interns
and so definitely getting the timing
right there and getting in early is
going to be important oftentimes smaller
companies though will recruit a little
later because they don't have quotas of
the number of interns they don't they
might not even have an intern program
set up even if you're getting into the
game a little bit later there are
definitely still possibilities for you
to get an internship another thing to
know especially as you're starting to
apply to these internships is that
online portals and career fairs are
going to feel like black holes you can
spend so much time in them they're also
very exhausting and you're going to look
at a lot of internship postings and it
can be entirely overwhelming in fact I
remember a time in probably my freshman
year where I was applying to five jobs a
day I set a minimum for myself like you
must be applying to five jobs every day
and this was completely ineffective
I remember seeing those charts where
people list out the number of companies
they applied to and the number of
interviews they got and how many passed
I was convinced that this was purely a
numbers game if I applied to enough I
would be guaranteed an internship this
is not true this mentality in fact was
super inefficient and I think there are
some better ways that I could have
approached that because likely if you
are applying to 20 jobs and no one's
accepting you then there's something
going over there yeah that like you
don't talk to a human being a lot of the
times if you're doing it through online
portals and job fairs are also
overwhelming because recruiters are
talking to hundreds of students every
day that they can't give you feedback
and so we're going to offer a couple of
other options for what are better ways
to
look for internships so the alternative
that we think is actually way more
efficient is finding contacts and
building relationships with people at
the companies that you want to intern at
at the end of the day creating
connections and establishing
relationships are going to make it way
easier for you to get your foot in the
door to get considered for the
internship because people know people
it's a lot easier for people to think
about other people for internships than
thousands of resumes so you can do this
through cold emailing and Linkedin
messaging to people who are recruiters
or engineers or anyone that you find at
these companies and you can also go to
meetups and other things to just like
get to know some people too and that's
actually how I got my first internship I
had a friend who is two years older than
me who just graduated and was working
for a company that I wanted an
internship at so I asked him hey can you
refer me and he got me in the door and
that's actually where I got my
internship and that was great because I
knew someone who was in the company who
could vouch for me to get me into the
program and that was the most best thing
that I could have done in order to get
that first internship so now that we
talked about how to prepare for applying
and then also applying for internships
now how do you prepare for an interview
when you get that interview for an
internship so we talked about how
getting an internship is kind of like a
game but if you want to play the game
well you need to practice even though it
might be hard you might feel like the
problems are super super difficult and
maybe impossible at the beginning know
that you will get better I would say
it's kind of hard to cram technical
interview practice so if you do think
this is something that you need to
improve on try to find ways that are
more efficient for practicing for
example I personally try not to spend
more than an hour an hour and a half on
any single problem I know that like once
I reach a certain point and I can't go
any further then I'm just I'm just stuck
and so in that case looking at the
solution will help inform me will help
teach me better than aimlessly hammering
at the problem for another two hours and
getting increasingly more frustrated
yeah and it's a lot around like
stimulating very similar circumstances
so you're likely only going to have an
hour to do a problem when
actually in the interview stimulating it
in terms of like doing it with another
person having a friend be they play the
role of the interviewer so that you can
be the interviewee in practice talking
through problems and talking through
your thoughts I actually made a video
about this a while ago so please check
that out I think it was how to prepare
for technical interviews which also has
a lot of great content it's a very
important part of just interviewing in
general for both internships and
full-time roles
it's unfortunate a little bit that it's
kind of like performing like for a match
literally and you keep like Kelly's that
you can't cram for that but that is the
nature of current interviewing standards
in the tech industry so yeah that's
definitely practice don't procrastinate
on this one part of the interview will
be non-technical as well so for this
portion what I found really helpful is
knowing a project or two a software
project that you can talk about in depth
be ready for the interviewer to ask a
lot of questions about this sometimes
they'll surprise you with things that
you might have not thought about before
but they're trying to get an insight
into how you think about these technical
problems and how you build things I've
also definitely been bit by like I think
I know a technical project pretty well
but then when I also try to talk about
it I can't so this is even something
that's really worth practicing to
remember like how that project went and
what the technical details were because
memories are faulty and you might not be
able to talk about it unless you give
yourself a little bit of a refresher so
definitely even setting up on like your
past history if you will is is really
helpful usually at the end of the
interview the interviewer will give you
a chance ask questions this is also an
important part of the interview
something helpful for me is always
having a list of questions in mind these
can be companies specific maybe about
specific teams at the company or
products or these can be more general
questions things like what has been the
most interesting technical challenge you
faced recently questions like that yeah
and as we talked about in the first
video of this series internships are a
great way to get to know who you are
and so you are asking the right
questions
you accompany to help you get some more
information around the company culture
the tech stack the people is going to
give you a lot of information so that
you can make the right decision for
whether this internship is going to give
you what you need to improve yourself to
learn more about yourself whatever that
thing may be I actually came across a
really good resource which was a github
project with a bunch of really good
questions you can ask a company and this
is both for internships and for
full-time roles so I'll leave a link for
that in the description box down below
as well so during the interview itself
you might be super intimidated or scared
I know I've definitely had interviews
where I've felt that way something that
might be reassuring is that the
interviewer is on your side okay usually
the interviewer has used the same
question many times so they kind of know
the tips and tricks that can help you
get to a solution sometimes they'll hint
things so try to pick up on that maybe
they'll even highlight lines of code
that you need to fix simple things like
that that can help you move along if
you're at a place where you're kind of
frozen what's often helpful is to start
with the simplest solution just getting
some code written getting something down
makes me feel better and that could work
for you as well yeah it's easier to
iterate on something than to have
something from or to create something
from scratch the whole like interviewers
on your side thing is actually really
interesting because I've definitely had
interviewers who nudge me towards the
right direction because they want to
unblock me to see what where my
strengths are so definitely they will
help you along and then also like
they've been in your shoes before
they've interviewed for that job they've
interviewed for an internship and they
must know how you're feeling
and hopefully they can empathize with
you and also help you along as well
you're not scary people they're just
human beings also if you're in that
position where you feel super stressed
and anxious about the interview just
know that every interview is an
opportunity to practice even if you
don't advance to the next round if you
don't get the job if you treat it like
an experience to learn rather than a
means to an end that will sometimes help
take the stress off
yeah if you think about it if you think
about in terms of this is the only thing
yeah that matters and that is very
structure and having that learning
mentality is definitely way easier to
get through because even if you know you
fail you'll know how you failed and you
can move on in the next time something
that's often overlooked too is that you
should be courteous to your interviewer
to your recruiter you definitely don't
want to be burning bridges especially
early on and treat them like you would a
normal human being
sending thank-you knows asking for
feedback on what you could be doing
better is really is a good thing it's a
courteous and sometimes you won't get
responses back and that's okay but if
you can get responses back that's really
good because then you can take that
feedback and do better next time and
learn from that so right now I've only
had opportunities to be interviewed but
I know my you go you've interviewed
people on the other side yeah definitely
and I mean a lot of these things are
true as well when I'm interviewing
someone I doesn't want to say yes to
somebody instead of no and so like I
mentioned before like getting them to
the point where they are thriving in the
technical interview being able to suss
out their strengths and their weaknesses
or the things that I'm looking for and I
know that it's stressful and so I like I
personally go above and beyond and be
like hey you're doing fine like it's
okay I'm to make sure that they're doing
all right because like technical
interviews are not always super fun to
even conduct because it's really hard to
assess someone's abilities based on a
one-hour problem but we're doing our
best to pick up on certain things based
on implementation based on communication
style and hopefully that helps too for
anyone who's out there who's
interviewing right now that it's it's
kind of like it's hard for everybody and
we're all really just trying our best to
communicate to each other what we're
good at so again getting an internship
is not the end-all be-all getting an
internship is not equal to success and
not getting an internship is not equal
to failure yeah and when I think about a
lot of the people who I've worked with
as a soft
engineer a lot of them didn't go to
college a lot of them don't have CS
degrees and they definitely don't have
an internship experience but they found
their way into the industry because
there are a lot of ways to get here
internships are a great playground and a
great opportunity if you have it and if
you can to experience a lot of different
things and learn a lot about yourself
and learn new skills
so hopefully the tips in this videos
will help you with that so we hope you
like this video the first video of the
series is around wire internships
important so definitely please check
that out and also check out Kelsey's
channel which is linked in the
description box down below give us a
thumbs up if you liked this video and
don't forget to click subscribe and
we'll see you next time bye who are you
what was I going to say don't bring it
and that enters you
okay